[Música]
en el año 2013 llevaba 15 años
trabajando en una empresa que se dedica
a la venta de material médico-quirúrgico
a priori la cosa no iba bien
a pesar de las crisis los números
seguían saliendo a nivel personal mi
mujer me seguía aguantando
mi hija crecía sana y sobre el papel
todo me iba bien
pero la verdad es que tenía un problema
cada mañana me levantaba y notaba que me
crecía una bola en el estómago algo no
iba bien
y va a cumplir 40 años
y lo peor de esto no son las primeras
canas
lo primero lo peor de esto es que me
empezaba a aburrir a pensar esto va a
ser así siempre comprar vender
crecer para qué
y yo había perdido la motivación no me
veía otros 25 años haciendo lo mismo
así que
me puse a buscar no sabía ni el qué
pero dije bueno hay que intentarlo me
apunté a todo suerte de cursos talleres
hasta que un día seis meses después un
amigo me dijo
esto te va a interesar
y tanto que me interesó
me enseñó un libro
en el cual los autores decían que no
empresa no solamente tenía que servir a
sus clientes servir a sus accionistas
pero que tenía que servir además cuidar
mimar a los intereses de los empleados
de sus empleados
al mismo nivel que sus clientes
era curioso
pero además tenía que servir los
intereses de la sociedad tenía que ser
un factor de cambio positivo en el mundo
las empresas tenían que cambiar el mundo
los autores de ese método de gestión
llamado a la dirección por misiones
habían descubierto que las típicas
palancas de motivación extrínseca sin
física intrínsecas que tenemos en las
empresas no bastaban
ellos a través de un libro muy pequeño
habían encontrado una forma sencilla de
pulsar la motivación trascendente que
tenemos todos la motivación
transcendente es esa motivación que nos
nace cuando nos ponemos al servicio de
los demás
un vendedor se puede cansar de vender
una ministra tivo se puede cansar de
pasar pedidos
pero a que un bombero ni se cansa ni se
aburre en el medio de un rescate porque
en juego hay algo más importante que el
mismo
está al servicio
así que empezamos por los empleados y
que hicimos bueno pues adoptar toda una
serie de medidas extraídas de la
psicología organizacional positiva
coche impersonal coaching de equipo
mindfulness desarrollo personal
todo esto acabó incluso en algo
extraordinario imprevisto un edificio
optimista
me vais a decir qué es esto de un
edificio optimista en google en paterna
no puede ser
pues no no es google porque por supuesto
somos una pyme y no tenemos el dinero de
google pero
algo hicimos diferente
nos pusimos a crear con un artista
valenciano llamado fernando giménez y lo
que hicimos fue transcribir todos
nuestros sueños nuestros valores
nuestros recuerdos positivos a las
paredes de nuestro edificio y lo
transformamos en en yuto sitio en españa
donde los empleados sienten que están en
su casa porque son las caras suyas la de
sus mascotas la de sus seres queridos
que están en las paredes del edificio
así que este edificio nos ayuda nos
ayuda a sentirnos bien nos ayuda a dar
lo mejor
esto iba muy bien pero claro había otro
reto que era el de transformar el mundo
salvar el mundo
el reto sencillo
como nos dedicamos a vender catéteres
sondas para los pacientes hospitalizados
críticos
cloud fue muy sencillo pensar en seguida
decir vamos a ayudar a los pacientes
queríamos generar sonrisas en los
hospitales queríamos decir más allá de
nuestros productos vamos a hacer algo
para ayudar a los pacientes a sonreír
nos pusimos a buscar y nos dimos cuenta
que en españa tenemos la suerte de tener
muchísimas ongs muchísimas asociaciones
que hacen la experiencia del paciente
más agradable
así que nos dimos cuenta muy rápidamente
que no podíamos ayudar no podíamos sumar
pero en esa búsqueda nos dimos cuenta de
una cosa nos dimos cuenta que había muy
poca gente que estaba haciendo algo para
los que cuidan de nuestros pacientes
para nuestros cuidadores para nuestros
profesionales sanitarios
me vais a decir pero bueno si el bombero
está motivado el profesional sanitario
también acaso necesitan apoyo acaso no
son profesiones altamente vocacional es
una motivación a prueba de bomba
pues resulta que no resulta que no es
así resulta que en eeuu el 54% de los
médicos especialistas no volverían a
repetir la misma carrera si tuviesen la
opción de elegir
54%
en inglaterra han calculado que si eres
mujer y doctora tienes 4 veces más
posibilidades de suicidarte que
cualquier otra persona
en españa no tenemos tantos datos porque
quizás no nos queramos asustar pero
resulta que al igual que a nuestros
países de países vecinos sabemos que
entre el 30 y el 50 por ciento de los
profesionales sanitarios padecen en
alguna medida un tipo de burnout
nuestros profesionales sanitarios están
quemados no pueden más
y claro eso tiene un impacto directo
sobre nosotros los pacientes
como nos van a cuidar
si ellos no están bien
es imposible de hecho el profesor
michael west de la universidad de
lancaster ha demostrado que los equipos
donde la gente no comunica no comparte
objetivos no confían en él entre ellos
salvan menos vidas que los equipos que
sí lo hacen
el profesor morales quezada de la
universidad de boston ha demostrado
que la empatía del médico tiene un
efecto curativo sobre el cerebro del
paciente ha demostrado que si una
persona médica es empática
eso va a ayudar a la curación del
paciente más allá de los medicamentos no
sólo los medicamentos curan
claro
si nosotros sabemos esto y que tenemos
por misión de salvar
generar más sonrisas en los pacientes
dijimos y ahora que como hacemos esto
y ahí es cuando nos inventamos algo nos
inventamos unos premios unos premios
para llamar la atención para decir al
mundo ojo que la salud psicosocial de
los hospitales es algo muy importante
así que creamos unos premios nacionales
en el año 2015 y esos premios o esos
premios nacionales pues desde entonces
han recibido unas 800 candidaturas
y han servido de inspiración sobre todo
a mucha gente para transformarse en lo
que hemos nosotros llamado un hospital
optimista
el optimismo en
organización sanitaria que puede ser
exactamente bueno entre paréntesis lo
que os voy a decir sobre optimismo nos
vale para la familia la empresa
cualquier organización no solamente es
sobre un hospital pero realmente el
optimismo lo que tenemos que tener muy
claro es que es la capacidad de buscar
lo positivo en cualquier situación
esto no tiene nada que ver con trabajar
de forma alegre trabajar de forma
relajada el happiness no tiene que ver
con buscar lo positivo se puede ser
positivo incluso cuando el barco se está
yendo a pique
así que
para dejar claro que es el optimismo
me puse a escribir un libro un libro
para ayudar a nuestros equipos
en ese camino tuve la inmensa suerte de
conocer una persona que me podía
entender muy bien y entender muy bien a
nuestras profesiones sanitarios conocí a
josé josé fonseca pires señor portugués
que era licenciado en medicina y doctor
en economía
y entre los dos descubrimos cinco rasgos
característicos de una organización
sanitaria optimista de un hospital
optimista el primer rasgo
y eso va a parecer raro pero el primer
rasgo tiene que ver con la capacidad de
los managers a entender lo básico que no
va se va a poder cuidar bien a los
pacientes si no se cuida de las
profesiones sanitarios
es obvio pero hay mucha gente todavía
muchos jefecillos que siguen pensando en
los humanos como recursos
el segundo rasgo tiene que ver con la
seguridad psicológica la seguridad
psicológica es un término que han
acuñado la profesora en vietnam son de
la universidad de harvard y tiene que
ver con la capacidad de los equipos de
generar ese clima en el cual la gente no
tiene miedo a exponer sus dudas en
público
esa seguridad que se genera cuando sé
que aunque no se lo puedo comentar en
público no voy a quedar en ridículo
os imaginais un servicio con 30 a 40
médicos en una sesión clínica
alguien que levante la mano y diga a
este paciente por qué no lo aplicamos el
mismo tratamiento que aquel de hace dos
meses
ese silencio aterrador esperando a la
respuesta
del jefe de servicio me está enseñando a
mí que no sé lo que estoy haciendo con
ese paciente
ya no hay más dudas ya no hay más
preguntas
por supuesto ya no se comparten
conocimientos por lo tanto el equipo
aprende menos y como el equipo aprende
menos comete más errores
y como comete más errores en monzón
también ha demostrado que salva menos
vidas
el tercer elemento de un hospital
optimista tiene que ver con políticas
promovidas por alta dirección que tienen
que promover la confianza de los
empleados hacia la institución tiene que
ver con políticas de igualdad de
oportunidades con políticas de
formación continuada no solamente en lo
sanitario sino con habilidades gestión
de conflicto a hablar en público todo
esto que nuestros profesionales
sanitarios no han recibido nada de
formación
por supuesto todas esas políticas tienen
que aplicarse con la máxima
transparencia os imagináis gestionar
plantillas de 78 mil trabajadores que
representan unas 180 funciones dentro
del hospital que trabajan por turnos
cuán importante es la transparencia la
comunicación el saber que todo el mundo
puede estar al tanto y disfrutar de las
mismas oportunidades eso es complicado
es uno de los rasgos también
característicos
el cuarto elemento tiene que ver
ahora es cuando me bloqueo
un aplauso no algo gracias
los jefes que no son jefes que son
líderes la seguridad psicológica las
políticas las políticas que generan
confianza
la cuarta me sigue sin aparecer bueno
son las cosas del directo la quinta me
la sé seguro la quinta
acs está bien la quinta me la sé
la quita tiene que ver con elemento más
mágico de todos tiene que ver
con esa búsqueda de la misión esa misión
que os hemos comentado de nuestra
empresa ese para que que nos ayuda a
aunar todas las voluntades detrás de
algo importante
y me vais a decir pero es imposible un
hospital
sí que es posible sí que es posible es
posible que la gente haga algo para los
demás más allá de su rol
es posible que la gente decida algo
decidida a ayudar a un colectivo
una carrera para la investigación un
espectáculo donde los profesiones
sanitarios se unen para actuar a favor
de unos niños de una asociación de niños
con cáncer una acción de promoción de la
salud en las escuelas públicas cualquier
cosa con tal de ir más allá de hacer
algo más importante que ellos mismos
porque cuando sucede esto y hay una y ya
no hay etiquetas ya no hay jefes de
servicio el doctor cirujano el auxiliar
todas estas etiquetas caen los roles
desaparecen aparecen personas que están
codo con codo luchando por algo más
grande que ellos mismos en estos
momentos la comunicación mejora
cuando hay comunicación la confianza el
orgullo de pertenencia así nacen los
equipos de alto rendimiento así nacen
los equipos de grandes cuidadores
sabemos muy bien que esto no es fácil
pero somos optimistas ya lo sabéis y
cuando las fuerzas flaquean nos
acordamos de la leyenda del colibrí
la leyenda de corear y la cuenta los
indígenas unos indígenas de suramérica
y la leyenda dice lo siguiente
estaban todos los animales en la jungla
en un momento dado se declaró un
terrible incendio todos los animales
salieron huyendo todos menos uno el
colibrí el colibrí
iba y venía entre el lago y el incendio
tirando las gotitas de agua que
transportaba en su pico
y en una de esas idas y venidas la
jirafa le dice colibrí no te das cuenta
que lo que haces no sirve para nada
y el colibrí miro a la jirafa y le dijo
lo sé pero yo estoy haciendo mi parte
así que nosotros en nuestra empresa
sabemos que somos unos pequeños
colibríes pero sabéis que es lo mejor
que vosotros también podéis hacer
colibrís y la única cosa que tenéis que
hacer
es la siguiente mirar a los
profesionales sanitarios como lo que son
unos superhéroes que nos cuidan cuando
más lo necesitamos muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]